[Aplausos]
hola qué tal
[Música]
bueno
soy diseñador de modas entonces no soy
speaker pero espero pueda hacerlo bien
el penacho de moctezuma se encuentra en
viena austria
el muro huichol hermosísimo que se
encuentra en parís y una de las más
grandes obras de frida kahlo que se
encuentran en alemania
todo este arte ha llegado ahí así como
900 piezas más de arte y reliquias
importantes mexicanas que están en el
extranjero han llegado por medio de robo
mercado negro adjudicación y también por
compra pero aquí la pregunta es por qué
el arte mexicano es tan amado en el
extranjero y a veces aquí no
para dónde es
ok
e
quisiera hablar de la del malinchismo
soy una persona que se considero
malinchista por mucho tiempo
para las personas que sean extranjeras o
los extranjeros que vean esto quisiera
explicar que es el machismo como todos
sabemos siendo mexicanos pues proviene
de la palabra malinche que es el
significado de malinalli el nombre de
una
indígena mexicana que fue muy importante
en la historia de méxico porque gracias
a ella los españoles pudieron conquistar
a méxico y además era una mujer muy
inteligente porque sabía hablar el
náhuatl el maya y aprendió rapidísimo
hablar el español
el nombre de malinche digo malinchismo
es un nombre que se ocupa para el
traidor de mexico para aquel que
prefiere apoyar al extranjero que a su
propio país
pero yo me pregunto si realmente
malinche fue traidora o la traicionaron
la historia de la malinche que
seguramente todos ya se la saben pero me
gustaría hacer hincapié en eso es que
era una niña que a los 7 años fue
huérfana de padre entonces su madre le
regaló al ejército maya y después como
esclava y después cayó en el ejército
azteca de la misma manera como esclava y
después los aztecas la vendieron no le
regalaron como tributo después de haber
perdido una batalla aquí en tabasco
entonces se la regalaron a los españoles
como parte de un objeto así como 19
chicas doncellas como tributo hacia los
españoles esta es la historia de la
malinche bueno hay muchísima más y tiene
muchísimas cualidades y era una mujer
muy sabia no era tan mala como la
historia la pinta y si ustedes buscan
ahorita hay nuevos historiadores que
hablan de lo buena de lo inteligente y
de lo sabia que fue no solo con los
españoles y también con y también con
méxico explicó
cuántas veces tú has criticado a méxico
a tu presidente cuántas veces has dicho
y estoy harta este país pura burocracia
narcotráfico estoy harta de
todo muchas veces criticamos nuestro
propio país y yo lo entiendo
principalmente yo que eso era una
malinchista pero
también nuestro país tiene cosas buenas
las críticas son muy buenas nos ayudan a
crecer pero también hay que pensar una
cosa la autocrítica porque porque yo
como paisano yo como mexicano yo como
habitante de cualquier equis país que
estoy haciendo por mejorarlo si no
empieza el cambio desde aquí
no vamos a cambiar tenemos que cambiar
nuestra manera de pensar nuestra manera
de actuar ok
nuevamente
recuerdo que bueno yo en esta plática
les quiero les quiero decir que me
acompañen por favor a ver y analizar
algunas pequeñas cosas que me pasaron en
la vida por las cuales yo decidí dejar
de ser mal en chiste por amar a méxico y
me enamoré completamente y quiero
invitarlos a que ustedes enamoren
también para que no solamente de decirlo
no solamente de palabra de vivirlo y de
sentirlo para que porque esto va a traer
beneficios a ustedes y no solo ustedes a
sus hijos a sus nietos a sus sobrinos y
a sus amigos recuerdo en alguna ocasión
participe en un evento en un concurso en
barcelona y posteriormente este concurso
me abrió puertas porque gane
fui una de las seleccionadas de las
ganadoras así que me agro puertas en
todo el mundo incluyendo milán
después de mi primera exposición en
milán recuerdo que todo mundo le encantó
todos los italianos rusos y mucha gente
que llegó dijo wow es que méxico es
grande
después de eso tenía yo que presentarme
nuevamente en españa- así que me dijeron
necesitamos que traigas más trabajo
artesanal entonces dije bueno yo voy a
buscarlo me fui a un pueblito muy
pequeño lejos de coque para llegar ese
pueblito me subí a un bus luego a un
camioncito donde llegaban gallinas y
frutas y otras cosas para llegar a este
lugar
llego y veo que las artesanas en este
lugar trabajaban en sus casas bordaban
pero me dio mucha tristeza ver que
también habían revendedores explotadores
que ellas todos los días
se acababan los ojos tejiendo tejiendo
tejiendo para venderlos super barato
pero no se lo pueden imaginar muy barato
entonces esto hace muy mal a nuestro
país porque entonces
los revendedores lo que hacen es que
evalúan el trabajo artesanal
lo hacen prometiéndoles a ellas que te
voy a dar me lo muy barato porque te voy
a dar trabajo continuo pero en realidad
si ellas vendieron su producto al precio
que se debe vender lo que vale bordar un
corsé de dos meses entonces ellas no
tendrían que trabajar todos los días
quemándose la vista por lo cual después
que regrese a italia y a europa mi mente
cambió y dije ya para mí la moda no es
solamente lo que yo estoy haciendo no es
solamente el glamour del mexican chic en
europa y en el mundo a mí me cambió
muchísimo mi manera de pensar esa visita
y además le dije a la señora señora
porque sigue trabajando esto mejor venda
fruta no se trabaje en casa de alguien
en la ciudad y me respondió saben qué
cosa me respondió
que está imaginen que me respondió
que eso sabía ser que piensa más que me
respondió
que le gustaba que piensan más perros o
no
necesidad no me respondió nada de eso
me dijo es que esto es lo que me enseñó
mi abuelita
es mi identidad
esto es lo que yo quiero que mis hijos y
mis nietos sepan esto es lo que yo
aprendí de mis ancestros es una es una
cultura que nosotros tenemos y yo no
quiero que se pierdan estas raíces me
quedé pensando y dije
no es posible que ella que lo vive todos
los días la tristeza la pobreza tratando
de salvar y preservar sus raíces no es
posible que nosotros que a veces estamos
en ciudades y tenemos las cosas más
fáciles estamos regateando cuánto es lo
menos cuánto es lo menos cuando se te
acerca me acuerdo me acuerdo muy cuando
era muy pequeña acuerdo mucho que se
acercaba la indita que nosotros llamamos
indica pues si una indígena con su
canasta de dulces y decía éste oye pues
comprábamos cosas pero yo decía oye no
puede ser a los siete años me
martirizada cuando mis compañeros se
fijaban en la en la bandeja de dulces
yo siempre estresada me martin saba
porque decía hoy están descalzos es una
abuelita o es un otro niño de mi edad
empecé a crecer y empresas empecé a
analizar más y empecé a juzgar un
poquito más esta situación porque siguen
hablando su lengua etcétera pero bueno
conociendo a esta señora me di cuenta de
muchas cosas
aquí está una de las fotos de las
artesanas
otra otra artesana que conocía en ese
viaje y bueno ahí fui com parte de mi
equipo que es mi hermana y esta es una
de las prendas que presentamos en milán
me recordé también que la fría calor le
encantaba el arte huaqueño y me puse a
investigar porque lo usaba tanto y una
de las cosas es por lo que significaba
no sólo por la belleza del bordado que
pueden tardarse meses incluso uno o dos
años en bordar un vestido nosotros
empezamos
a promover este arte para que sea
valorado y bien pagado y desde el
artesano hasta el cliente final
posteriormente fue una vez ha sido de
mexico y estuve buscando inspiración me
encontré con el arte huichol
me acuerdo que fui a coyoacán y me
entrevisté con un muy sol y le dije oiga
[Música]
desde cuando hace esto me dice desde que
tenía 7 años y le dije oiga de dónde es
usted no pues de wirikuta y le dije a
usted no le convendría más trabajar de
otra cosa en la agricultura en la pesca
me dice no es que la verdad
el piso es árido y no se dan muchas
cosas es muy pobre por eso ok
terminamos de platicar de otras cosas
colores la inspiración y el misticismo
huichol su religión ellos todavía siguen
creyendo pues en la naturaleza en la
madre naturaleza y en el equilibrio esto
me pareció muy sabio de ellos ellos
siempre están en busca de la paz
interior por medio de la naturaleza y
sus dioses son la naturaleza y la
naturaleza es creada por dios entonces
yo no tengo nada en contra de eso y
tampoco veo nada de malo
el recuerdo qué
casi me hizo llorar cuando le compré
bastantes piezas este señor se le
pusieron los ojos llorosos y me dijo
muchas gracias y le dije porque usted
casi llora y me dice
youtube no no me hubiera comprado esto
yo no hubiera podido mantener a mi
familia en uno o dos meses yo con esto
voy a poder mantener a mi familia elegí
señor porque no se viene a vivir a la
ciudad de mexico y así ya no va a tener
usted que sufrir ni sé por qué no voy a
dejar week utah porque wirikuta ahí está
nuestra tierra
donde nosotros hacemos nuestros rituales
y nos conectamos con nuestros dioses
y si nos vamos van a llegar estas
empresas canadienses que es un tema
internacional esto de hecho yo aparte de
esto después me enteré en milán que de
estas cosas es un tema internacional que
empresas extranjeras están llegando a
esta zona eur y culta que está en la
sierra madre occidental y quieren poner
sus plantas sus empresas de minería que
van a contar también el contaminar el
subsuelo y también además de eso que hay
poca agua pues entonces ahí sí se va a
morir toda la gente obviamente ellos me
dicen si yo me voy entonces quién va a
cuidar esta tierra además que es la
tierra con la que yo me conecto con mis
dioses
saben que sentí yo con eso me dio muchas
ganas de llorar me dio coraje investigue
no a nadie ha hecho nada el gobierno no
quiero hablar mal de él y tampoco estoy
tan enterada tampoco soy periodista y no
me consta lo que viene en las redes pero
saben que dije yo no soy periodista
no soy speaker
lo único que puedo hacer es poner mi
granito de arena porque tú lo que
siempre es como dice la ley del karma
como dice la ley de la atracción como
dice la biblia lo que siempre se cosecha
y quizá tú no le vas a cosechar quizá va
a ser tu sobrino tu primo tu hijo tu
nieto así que yo dije yo voy a empezar a
hablar de este tema es lo único que
puedo hacer y continuar impulsando el
trabajo huichol en mi arte y lo voy a
seguir haciendo y se está poniendo de
moda de hecho esto que traigo es huichol
se está poniendo de moda y lo voy a
seguir poniendo más de moda y va a
causar una tendencia y yo por eso es que
estoy aquí para que escuchemos más a los
huicholes y los invito a ver una
película que se llama
los guardianes del peyote y le encuentra
en youtube y habla sobre estos temas y
está súper interesante
ya casi terminó
yo tengo un equipo ítalo mexicano
empezamos siendo mexicanos todos y
ahorita se ahorita no hace algunos años
se adjuntó el lugar
luca es un visionario empresario que
también tiene un proyecto muy grande
para méxico y para los campesinos pero
no voy a hablar en este momento de luca
para no salirme del tema luca desde que
había mi trabajo me dijo ey llévalo
europa y yo le dije no porque quizá para
como para que se lo van a poner ellos y
me dijo llévalo a europa sabiamente
le hice caso porque yo no creía en mí y
tampoco creía que fuera a usar tanto él
fue el primero que me dijo esto así que
yo lo llevé este italiano sabio milanés
me lo dijo y ya ahora comprendí porque
me dijo las cosas
me lo dijo porque ellos en europa ya
perdieron no no no no quiero generalizar
pero en muchos países de europa y
norteamérica ya perdieron lo que tienen
méxico y latinoamérica que todavía
tenemos etnias tenemos 68 etnias cada
una con sus tradiciones cultura folklore
y religiones algunas con religiones
distintas a la católica religiones
ancestrales costumbres aquí les muestro
una cosa que me da mucha tristeza y que
luca fue una de las primeras cosas que
me dijo original y copia
aquí nuestro arte made in italy se está
perdiendo por original y copia que pasa
llegaron las empresas transnacionales
fashion
y la industrialización y se perdieron
las raíces yo lo que les digo es no
perdamos nuestras raíces
rescatemos nuestro méxico promovamos lo
bueno de nuestro méxico méxico no solo
es narcotráfico y malas noticias mexico
es amor es amado por el mundo así que
nosotros investiguemos y conozcamos
nuestro méxico y enamore me enamoré
monos de nuestro mexico aún más porque
tú tus hijos sus nietos son la cosecha
que van a ver el amor por méxico y no me
refiero sólo el ámbito del arte
artesanía y moda me refiero a todos a
todos los ámbitos
muchísimas gracias y los invito a
enamorarse de mexico hasta luego
[Aplausos]